bonsoir jean pierre commande est perçue
avec nous en direct sur arte france la
cnil qui demande donc au ministère de
l'intérieur de cesser d'utiliser les
drones est ce que c'est une décision
vous comprenez soit de toute façon que
je ne la comprennent ou pas elle est
incontournable ses décisions s'imposent
à tous
honnêtement je trouve que l' usage ou
pas des drones avec toutes les
préoccupations qui secoue actuellement
et la police et la société consiste un
débat franchement secondaire il y avait
déjà des moyens de prendre des images de
capter des images lors des
manifestations le drone c'était un petit
peu la plume sur le chapeau mais pour
moi c'est d'avoir un débat qui est né au
niveau tertiaire on sait pas du tout les
des préoccupations qui devrait occuper
l'esprit de ceux qui nous dirigent qui
le commande
donc en gros pour bien qu'on comprenne
quand même ce n'est pas une grosse perte
entre guillemets pour les policiers
s'étaient pas un outil indispensable
non pas du tout or si vous discutez avec
des policiers terrain croyez moi que les
sujets de préoccupation et d'intérêts
sont tout autres la sécurité sur le
terrain la pérennité de leur mission le
police bashing auquel on assiste depuis
des mois maintenant depuis trop
longtemps en tout cas des discours
politiques qui sont à géométrie variable
incompréhensible
au niveau du terrain et ça c'est un
problème majeur c'est vraiment pas le
drone n'est absolument pas dans l'ordre
des préoccupations de tout un chacun
je parle des policiers bien sûr alors le
bourreau de la sécurité doit se tenir le
25 janvier prochain vous avez participé
à écouter les associations que je
rappelle se représente pas du tout un
syndicat je représente une association
qui est justement indépendante
politiquement et syndicalement je crois
pas savoir que le ministère de
l'intérieur est convié des policiers
ayant animé s'est dite association de
qu'on appelle communément des
associations de policiers en colère
maintenant si vous me demandez mon avis
quant à savoir quel est le sens et
l'intérêt de ce beau mot je vous
répondrais très directement qu' on est
dans le cadre d'une politique
d'affichage pure et simple qui n'a pas à
mes yeux aucun intérêt si le ministère
où le gouvernement de s'interroger avant
des réponses sur ce qui préoccupe les
policiers la citoyenneté
je leur envoie très simplement aux
multiples rapports de commissions de
d'entretiens avec les organisations
syndicales
tous les outils sont déjà sur la table
du ministère pour savoir ce qui ne va
pas ce qui ne va pas ce non seulement au
niveau de l'institution en termes de
moyens en terme de moyens techniques
logistiques et aussi en termes de
problématiques que de relations entre la
population et la police
on est dans la communication pure de mon
point de vue c'est pas du mien je vois
sur une politique d'affichage comme on a
l'habitude maintenant des voir depuis
très longtemps depuis les débats
citoyens on discute beaucoup on parle
beaucoup des policiers attendent bien
autre chose et j'ai envie de vous dire
pas simplement des policiers quand on
part de la police faut replacer tout
cela dans le contexte
ce qui concerne la police concerne la
citoyenneté concerne la vie dans notre
société
si on continue à déstabiliser et à
dévaloriser comme on fait depuis de trop
nombreux mois de même donc pour dire de
trop nombreuses années l'institution
police c'est l' équilibre même de la
société qui est en danger
lorsque la police sera totalement
désarmé je parle pas simplement d'armes
létales mais désormais juridiquement et
dans le sens donné à ces missions il
faudra vraiment s'inquiéter et on le
voit déjà dans les manifestations de
deux heures quand je
une manifestation dans la façon dont
s'explique les gangs sur le terrain qui
ne craignent plus rien ni personne qui
s'attaquent à tout ce qui a pu sacré on
parlait récemment d'une crash mais ça
fait très longtemps que ça durait trop
longtemps auriez un assortiment
véritable d'impunité du monde de la
délinquance qui se targue d'être
soutenus par des groupes de pression
totalement est trop démagogique des bd
semble d'ailleurs sur notre antenne vous
avez qualifié la situation de de cirque
vous êtes toujours manifestement aussi
sceptique sur cette réforme de
l'institution pour vous rien de bon ne
peut en sortir
non non pour une raison très simple
c'est que comme j'ai dit et répété et
très souvent tout ça s'inscrit dans une
sorte de déstructuration du service
public la première matic que rencontre
la police avec des formes différentes
bien entendu rejoint les problématiques
de la santé publique de la
déstructuration de des hôpitaux dans
notre pays gluck plus globalement de
l'institution santé au travers du
service public et on pourrait également
ajouter à sable le monde de
l'enseignement donc tout ça est un tout
tout ça forme un tout d'une philosophie
guy est maintenant plusieurs années
maintenant qui consiste à dévaloriser le
système de service public dans son
ensemble et donc bien évidemment la
police n'y échappe pas on sait très bien
que certains ont des arrières pensées de
décaler le pouvoir régalien vers soi des
polices municipales soient carrément
vers des entreprises privées de sécurité
et c'est là qu'est le vrai débat et moi
je regrette systématiquement j'ai fait
sur votre antenne je fais également au
travers d'articles auquel je participe
sur le les sites du net
au travers d'articles il y a quelque
chose qui dépasse les des sujets actuels
qui va il faut aller bien au delà on met
en avant toute la problématique de ce
qu'on qualifie violences policières
on ne parle pas bien évidemment de la
violence des délinquants et c'est bien
dommage parce que je vous inviterai
sincèrement à vous rapprocher des
victimes d'actes d'ultra violence et
vous verrez que le son de cloche est un
petit peu différent donc il faut
vraiment toujours avoir conscience que
sûr que nous assistons au niveau de la
santé de l'enseignement de la police et
de la justice s'inscrit dans une
dynamique pour objectif à terme de
réduire la portion congrue
tout ce qui est le service public et qui
coûte cher c'est vrai mais qui rend bien
des services à
à bien des égards merci beaucoup
jean-pierre colombien se porte parole de
l'union des policiers nationaux
indépendants d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur arte france